-Guys, as you know, every week,
we like to bring you
some uplifting, creative videos,
whether they come
from quarantine or just
stuff around the country.
It is time for
"What Are You Doing Wednesday."
♪ Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday ♪
♪ What are you doing?
It's Wednesday ♪
-First, this guy found
a new use for Q-tips.
-Oh. Okay. Okay. Okay.
-Q-tips.
[ Heavy-metal music playing ]
-Aah. Aah!
[ Screams ]
[ Heavy-metal music playing ]
Ow! Ow!
-Yeah.
-Ahh.
-All those Q-tips.
If I were him, I wouldn't
do dat, do dat,
do do, dat dat dat.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter ]
-Deep Cut by James Fallon.
-I knew I'd get you on that one.
Whew.
-Great.
-Next, these people found
a whole new way to drink water.
Watch this.
[ Dance music thumping ]
♪♪
-CCCCCKKKK!
With a little soap,
that counts as a shower.
Here's another video. Check out
this dad playing with his kid.
It's cute.
-[ Laughs ] Ow!
Ow!
-[ Growls ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Ow!
-Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
-Broke the skin on that one.
Got teeth.
The kid's -- he's teething.
And finally, this person
has a pretty photogenic dog.
This is pretty cool.
Take a look.
♪♪
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
Ohh! [ Laughs ] Come on!
That last --
That last one's a gem, dude!
There you have it.
That was
"What Are You Doing Wednesday."